and coming up we will take a closer look
at the salary cap casualties have
already occurred and maybe some of the
ones that still continue one guy who
will not be a cav casualty is dak
prescott officially signed his four-year
160 million dollar contract yesterday
with 75 million paid out in year one
jerry jones who had 30 000 or more fans
most of the season not one of the owners
who has to worry about
having cash on hand to do business
here's dak signing the contract uh and
let's hear from dak first talking about
the deal that he signed to stay in
dallas for at least the next four years
i grew up a dallas cowboy fan never in a
million years did i
imagine not being a cowboy once i put on
this uniform and put on this star uh so
through it all through the two years i
guess you can say or more there was
never a slight doubt in my mind that i
wouldn't wear the star for the rest of
my life and as charlotte told me a
couple of days ago as when you sign that
line uh you're a cowboy forever and you
can't get out and
uh i'm excited for that i'm excited to
be to be here and to never leave um i'm
excited for what this organization with
this team um what the fans are going to
get and i'm excited just to go do it and
just to know that this is my home i'm
not leaving i'm a cowboy and this is
only the beginning is just so much
excitement for everybody that is
involved and invested you did this tag
game for almost two years and it was you
know it's something that's been talked
about
it doesn't seem like you'll have to do
that next time you're available to
negotiate a deal yeah i mean i think uh
any player that's up to negotiation i
have an obligation um to support and
represent the rest of the nfl and where
this game is going and i think mr jones
just said it uh this contract shows
where this game is going um financially
right uh not just in the quarterback
position but in in all the positions uh
so obviously uh years later when i'm
back at it it'll be in different
circumstances but i think i had a
responsibility and obligation uh to the
other quarterbacks and to the other men
and even the guys on my team uh to get
this done
i love the justification and i hear you
selfish to be selfish right right but
but think about that there is truth to
it
there is truth to it but but think about
it i got every last penny i could get
for me
for me myself and my family i got all of
it i grabbed it all i i had them over a
barrel and i squeezed as hard as i could
i'm mixing my metaphors but the point is
i was
was selfish
to the highest degree
because i got to do it for everybody
else
i got to be selfish to be selfless i
love it i get you twisted up in a not
mentally he's right
but man i you know it's just some of the
stuff that was said yesterday and i get
it yesterday wasn't the occasion to rub
anyone's face in it but this whole idea
of cowboy for life he's a cowboy for
four more years yeah right and the
contract was specifically constructed
multiple different ways to keep the
cowboys from ever using the franchise
tag on him again we talked about it the
other day all the things they did to
make sure that after three years and 126
million the cowboys are gonna come back
to the table and based upon wherever the
cap is then wherever the cash is then
wherever the game is then pay him
accordingly so i
again yesterday was a day for
celebration and happiness and bringing
everyone together but the idea that dak
is guaranteed to be a cowboy for life is
ridiculous and the idea that he did this
for all the other guys out there who
have contracts that that at some point
are going to be renegotiated and this
allows them to get more well it does but
it's more of an incidental benefit this
wasn't a primary focus the primary focus
is get paid everything you can and if
you can say after the fact i helped some
other people great that's better than
saying i didn't no you're right the
primary focus was you know maximizing
his leverage as you what you brought up
so many times which he had great
leverage in the situation not only
because of the franchise tag and what it
would mean for next year if they did it
again and then we talked about the
football x's and o's leverage right the
team's not good the passing game is the
only thing to look at that's an elite
unit on their football team right now
and whoa we don't have a quarterback for
the future to take advantage of that so
his leverage was maximum there and yes
for his own reasons he took advantage of
that and i'm you know i i know we're the
same there we're never going to be mad
at that definitely not now there is you
know that
sense though in league circles when you
get in the nfl and do things like that
where
you know again a lot of the times we you
know commend the guy who takes less and
do that but i can say through the years
you know there'd be players where
wait this guy's the one or two best
players at his position
in football right and i'd have a
teammate who would be going hey i'm
gonna i'm about to resign a new contract
as soon as this year's up so they were
looking at that contract because oh hey
i'm just a little bit below that guy
right and they're looking at that guy
going what's he gonna sign for because
he's gonna dictate the market and push
it up
hopefully uh to where i can maximize
more for what i get and there were
instances where that guy who was one or
the one or two best at their position
they'd sign for
less and do the team a favor
and yeah you'd have guys or that guy i'm
talking about in the locker room or guys
in the nfl in general who are going damn
you know that's going to affect me now
i'm not going to be able to you know
push my price up here because he didn't
really you know stress
stress his leverage that he had so that
is a real aspect and i'm with you i
don't think that's the reason dak
prescott did that but it's like the
unintended consequence and it is good
for other quarterbacks
tom brady is the prime example of that
and there was a period of time from
about 2013 through 2017 where the
quarterback market stagnated yes and one
of the reasons it's stagnating is tom
brady who was having a great run in that
window right was not insisting on
blowing out the market getting the top
dollar and then and that's how it works
the more you stretch the more others can
fall in behind roger's finally the case
where yeah it's not necessarily a case
where brady's contract is going to be
surpassed but when brady's so low you
have two things happen you have other
quarterbacks who have a hard time
getting their full value and you have
other members of the patriots at the
time who have a hard time getting their
full value because there's always that
attitude spoken or unspoken who do you
think you are right tom brady's not
taking the maximum money why do you
think that you have any right to that uh
if he's not doing it and and so that's
the flip side so to the extent that
there is an obligation to help others
tom brady has not respected that
obligation for about 20 years well and
there's been some players there
right that
have been left there and been
disgruntled about you know what they
made
when they were there or and i want to go
well that was your fault you guys all
drank the kool-aid i don't know what
else to say
you know you yeah okay you took less you
went you won super bowls and did that
but now oh now it's towards the end of
your career and you're pissed off you
didn't make more money well that was
your fault i don't know what to say
about that uh so that is that is right
and you know that's where i know peyton
manning with quarterbacks around the
league and just players in general
he was loved that way because he always
pushed the market you know brady did
that early on in his career but then
like you said kind of backed off and
just went okay let's have a team and do
all those type of stuff but you know
that's a real aspect and you do see that
out of the ex new england players who
are a little disgruntled by all that
stuff
i know this is about dak but let me
throw you a curve ball i was out with
dan patrick yesterday and he suggested
what if tom brady just says to the
buccaneers take my 25 million dollars in
compensation this year and pay me the
minimum 1.075 million is the minimum for
anyone with seven or more years of
service has to be at least that what if
he would do that yeah have you had
23.925 million in cap dollars and cash
available to keep the team together he'd
be in the perfect position to do that
and that's the exact opposite of what
dak has done this is taking as little as
possible to make sure that the band can
be held together and tom brady can
pursue number eight and for him getting
number eight is far more valuable than
whatever the buccaneers could pay him
this year i i yes but you know
it also seems like the time in new
england
kind of stopped because he felt like
they didn't value him the proper way and
stuff like that too so
the buccaneers value him
i know he's great he's the best thing as
you like to say since sliced bread yeah
so you know they value him they love him
hey hey baby let's go let's go get
another one and uh boy it'd be nice if
we had another 23.925 million i hear
that you know but you know i i and and
tom brady early in his career i mean he
literally used to ask and go i will not
accept one dollar less than peyton
manning and he changed and i give him a
lot of credit for that we've talked
about he was forced into a corner a
little bit and all that but
at the same time i look at it now where
i go
no
you know
again i don't look at him as the best
quarterback ever but he's the goat he's
bringing so much damn money to that team
and jersey sales and all that you know
that would you know it'd be a cool story
but man i mean he has some valuable
unbelievable asset when you talk to
people who are at the super bowl this
year right
and they were down there in tampa
my dad for instance here we go he's at
the store and he's going to buy my
little boy
a jersey right he wants to buy him a
jersey okay i'm at the super bowl let me
get one of these jerseys oh he's got a
mahomes jersey okay he goes over to the
rack there's a huge rack
of tampa bay jerseys he starts looking
through it
there's nobody on the team other than
tom brady's jersey there the whole thing
and you know he looks at the woman and
is like it's only 12 jerseys there's no
nothing else and she goes yeah they sell
like hot cakes we don't need another
jersey out here and that just says it so
i don't know i feel like he's got such
legendary status and i don't know his
money situation we know his wife made a
lot of money and all that too so i don't
want to you know try to act like i know
but i i just feel like it he deserves to
be paid at this point he's a legend he's
going to have statues everywhere he's
the man
i have not audited his family's
financial statements but let's just say
there's they're okay there they're doing
fine right but you know you're right he
does move the needle yeah think about it
starting and this is a coincidence this
has nothing to do with you but starting
with your arrival they began to have a
hard time filling the stadium yeah in
tampa no doubt and that got worse not
better and now they can't wait to open
the gates and allow everyone who wants
to attend attend because they're gonna
have a full house for the first time
since their their first super bowl year
of 2002 right and brady is the catalyst
for that remember when bruce arians
continued to criticize tom brady last
year and at one point i was told
ownership's not real thrilled with this
because their main objective this year
is to make sure brady comes back next
year right because they want to make all
the money next year they're not making
this year but anyway that that's let's
get back to that that was a good talk
let's go back to dak prescott a guy
who's made a ton of money over the
course of his career and has plenty to
burn but would like to burn as little as
possible on his players here's jerry
jones talking about his new contract
with dak prescott
the decisions that i've had to make
in my time with the dallas cowboys
was to have dak prescott as a future
regarding the quarterback position of
the dallas cowboys the truth is
most anything that i've ever been
involved in
that ended up being special i over paid
for
every time to the end
anytime i've tried to get a bargain
i got just that it was a bargain
in a lot of ways and not up to standard
about the time that
i thought i had it all figured out
not our deal with dak but about the time
i thought i had a lot of things figured
out along came kovit
and uh
all of a sudden
you know i have been in the national
football league when it couldn't pay its
bills
that's how i got here
and it couldn't pay its bills and that's
not an exaggeration
and so you've got to look at the lay of
the land as it evolves
and anybody that beginning last year
didn't look at the overall lay of the
land so i'm going to blame a little of
that ambiguity that happened with the
covid business and what have you on any
measure that i might have had about well
is this is this
how do we go and really how do we
structure and how do we plan on going
forward we just had luxury i don't know
if that's the case but we had the
ability
uh i agree with you that there you could
say well boy you sure left dak hanging
out there
real good well
obviously
he has
the temperament for that
and i'm glad here
it's not as simple as dak wins
jerry wins cowboys win let me tell you
one thing
the cowboys won today
they won today
and i'm excited about this future and
that's what we're all interested in is
the future
he is such a good salesman that he could
make a compelling case for dumping water
into a trash can that's how good of a
salesman jerry jones is
we got to strip all that away i'm happy
to overpay anything great i've ever had
over paid for baloney he's always
looking for bargains that's how they got
into this problem because they thought
they could get dak to sign a deal that
was favorable to them and they misread
his resolve and they thought he'd be
more like tony romo who never pushed the
envelope because he was undrafted and as
we said earlier in the week he's just
happy to be here he already won the
lottery by being the starting
quarterback of the cowboys how much he
makes it's relative degrees it doesn't
matter he's making more than ever
thought he'd make playing football in
the nfl so they thought they'd get back
to take less
they painted themselves into a corner
and their only way out was four years
160 with no way to tag him when this
deal expires and as a practical matter
they got to be back to the table after
three years 126 42 million a year for
the next three years
the rest of it is just talk and i don't
expect him to sit there and say man we
really screwed up somebody asked me the
other day who won this heavyweight fight
i said dak won by tko because the
cowboys kept punching themselves in the
crotch yeah it's their own fault they're
the ones who made this mess they're the
ones who allow dak to get the money that
he's going to get yeah no you're right i
mean they made their bed they're going
to lay in it now but it's not like that
horrible bed to lay in i mean certainly
not you know we've hit all those reasons
and prescott you know brings something
to that football team you know you say
what you want about prescott even there
in that press conference once again it
just shows uh to me he just exudes man's
man or guy that you want to be a leader
he says all the right things you know i
know we've said this a lot he's got you
know all the tangibles on the field and
all the intangibles off the field and to
me you know when you are the dallas
cowboy quarterback i mean that's what
jerry jones wants he wants that that
roger stallback troy aikman tony romo
you know
there's there's a presence about the guy
when he's not in the locker room when he
walks into some you know restaurant you
just go man man look at that guy that's
the man if there's a man in the
restaurant it's him there he is dak
prescott has that type of presence about
him yeah they overpaid so what yeah i'm
not gonna buy sit there and go oh
anything he's ever done he's overpaid
blah blah blah i mean i remember emma
smith having to sit out two games and
then he finally overpaid him when he
realized whoa we're owen two and i have
a really good football team and i think
this is one of those moments once again
where he was just like okay
all right he got me you know i know
they're not in the season of losing
games but he understood the the the
value of dak in the situation to what
his team is at right now and
you know we'll go back to something
we've been saying for two years he's not
getting any younger so i didn't i don't
think he wanted to like rebuild or try
to start and find a new quarterback and
roll the dice doing that you know i
don't think that had any benefits at
this point either so they got it done
yeah he overpaid but like you've said
many of times too
we'll probably look at we're going to
look at this contract two or three years
from now and go oh you know it's like
aaron rodgers a few years ago when he
signed it we went well this kind of
blows everybody out of the water and now
you look at it and he's the what the
sixth seventh highest paid quarterback
uh i'm not saying it's going to go to
that but it certainly won't be the
highest contract in football you know
after the next two or three years
and let me let me address that in a
second but first i have to say what i
have a vision of 11 12 year old chris
sims following the emmett smith holdout
and loving every second of it because it
helped the giants oh what emmett smith
holding out and the cowboys to be losing
football yes i was so disappointed when
he came back you know that did my my dad
93 giants dan reeves first year there
that ended up being the year where
emmett played the last game of the year
and hurt his shoulder and did all that
stuff so you know
i was very aware at that point of how
awesome the cowboys were you know my dad
played against them of course the year
before when they won the super bowl and
i remember him saying even back then and
he'll say it now it might be the best
team i've ever played against so and he
still holds that he looks at that 92-93
cowboys team is the best team he ever
played against in his 15-year nfl career
uh and of course emma smith was a big
part of that
now you touched on the other issue where
the money's going to keep going up and
there's this strange narrative that has
popped up over the past couple of days
and it is so goofy to me the idea that
jerry jones has some sort of magic
crystal ball that he knows how much
money is coming in the new tv deals
and people in the media
are pushing that like they've tripped
over some incredible take that no one
has considered are you freaking kidding
me anyone who's been paying attention
knows what's coming the tv deals are on
the t they could be announced this week
and it's going to be a ton of money this
isn't jerry jones acting like some
oracle well you know there's going to be
a lot of money coming up here of course
there's going to be a lot of money
coming up
in that of course but but everybody
knows it he's not privy to some special
information because hey you know why
jerry did this jerry knows this just
sounds like some of the same bs we were
hearing yesterday oh jerry knows that
more money is coming of course it is do
you think that's why he paid him 160
million over four years no he did it
because he had to because billionaires
don't get there and they don't stay
there by doing bad deals you make as
much as you can you spend as little as
you can that's how you get rich that's
how you stay rich so don't give me this
crap and i've seen it time and again
over the past two days and people just
like lemmings they follow along that
well yeah jerry knows something we all
don't know we all know yeah
all the owners know that the money is
coming this isn't some opportunity to
say hey jerry you cracked the code again
he didn't no the code got cracked on him
and now they spent yesterday making it
look like it didn't happen well yeah
you're right but at the end of the day
at least it's over and i know he's he's
happy about that and he's got his
quarterback he doesn't have to deal with
that anymore and the worst oh yeah
he's got to deal with it in three years
and the one thing the one thing i'll say
with jerry too and he brought it up a
little bit in that that part there
hey there's a reason jerry jones is
jerry jones he is one of the the
godfather owners of the nfl right i mean
you you correct me you probably know
more than i do here but
jerry jones and robert kraft are the two
guys that i think are held in the
highest regard as far as the owners
because of what they did business-wise
for the nfl and growing it and making
dollars at least that's everything
anybody i've been connected to knew
right like he talked about the nfl
couldn't pay its bills and he
of course came into the league and
changed how they did you know commercial
deals and all that type of stuff and uh
and sponsorship and all that and he's
made the nfl a powerhouse unlike it ever
was before uh i don't know am i am i
right about that or you're right yeah
and you know how he changed it you know
he changed it he took a page out of the
al davis playbook he sued the league for
750 million dollars because they
wouldn't let teams cut their own
marketing like the coke pepsi thing
right yeah exactly right when when
jerry jones showed up in 1989 the nfl
was still at that time
for the for the most part a bunch of
family-owned businesses
that had limitations on the extent to
which they acted like the billion dollar
businesses they were in the process of
becoming they were still years away from
being billion dollar businesses but they
were on that trajectory but
they didn't have the business acumen to
get there so as the as the
billionaires out there or people who are
on track to become billionaires saw the
potential and bought these teams when
they became available and you know jerry
jones bought the cowboys from the
original group
that founded the team nearly 30 years
before right when guys like him guys
like robert kraft who arrived five years
later
other guys who made a lot of money
elsewhere and brought those business
principles to football that's what
helped turn it into what it now is so
now the prevailing presence is
someone who has made a ton of money
elsewhere who has bought a football team
there are still the rooneys the maris
there's and the alice's yeah
they're full but now people but now but
and and and hey you know some some of
those teams have a hard time keeping up
with the jerry joneses of the world
because he brings a business
savvy that's what makes this so ironic
that of all the owners out there the one
who got hoisted on his own petard
because he misread a negotiation is
jerry jones he should be the last one to
so badly misread a negotiation no you're
right you know hey karma even gets
billionaires that's just the way it is
that's okay this is one i think you know
like he said hey there was covid and
those issues a course in injury
they misread you know dak prescott's
like you said stubbornness and belief in
self and all of those type of things
and he finally met his match there and
you know it's all right he's he's won a
lot of the business deals like you've
talked about so it's okay i'm not gonna
sit here and shed a tear that he lost
one to to a guy that's a franchise
quarterback and done everything right
since he set foot in the nfl
he plans to win a business deal this
year as it relates to the pandemic as i
mentioned earlier they had more than 30
000 fans on multiple occasions in 2020.
here's jerry jones from yesterday
talking about his expectations for 2021
do i see a more promising economic
future
for the nfl
maybe than others
okay i've seen that said this tells you
all you need to know about what you
think about the future of the nfl this
says that loud and clear
now we're going to oxnard
we're going to have training camp
we're going to do it safe
and we're going to have that stadium
full
and we're going to do it safe we had the
most out there last year we're going to
do it safe
and we
if if this contract manifests anything
it's our belief that this decision right
here is about how we take the next step
today and take on off tomorrow
god he's he's buying the bs that he's
somehow the only person who understands
that the nfl is going to make more and
more and more money with the tv deals
and the pandemic being over but they are
going to have full stadiums in texas i
think the texas rangers said it right
baseball team they're going to be the
first team
nationwide to have full stadiums and
look hey
the pandemic
i don't want to jinx anything
but the vaccination roll out yeah you
know that we're moving in the right
direction right we're moving the right
direction i'm getting mine today good
for you my needle today way to go i mean
i i assume it's one of the ones where
you have to get two shots for all i know
it's johnson and johnson i only have to
get one someone who understands this
stuff very well and this is my message
anyone out there has any misgivings
right get the vaccine and it doesn't
matter which one they all work and
they're all safe get the vaccine yeah
but
the bottom line is that's what's going
to allow jerry jones to make this money
back it's not justification for doing a
bad deal with dak prescott they did a
bad deal with dak prescott but one way
to feel better about it is there's
plenty of money that's still going to
flow into everyone's pockets associated
with the nfl in the coming years yeah
that's right
i'm i'm you know again i'm not worried
about it they're going to be fine he
knows what's coming we all know what's
coming it's the first year ever we've
seen a dip in the nfl and what they've
made money-wise and all that they're
going to be back on that cash cow you
know by the end of next year and then
we're going to hit on this a little bit
in the next segment which i'm excited to
dive into
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports